Fine!
No loop!
You're gonna watch, you're gonna have to wait here and watch
me order a monitor arm then.
Oh my god.
Yes.
I was trying to order a monitor arm.
Even in bed.
Bring back the loop.
what happened it's finally dead that monitor arm that i've
kept for i don't even know how many years i think it's been
four years it's been four years and i've been like trying to
keep it alive it's it's dying it's like on its deathbed and
i like kept pumping adrenaline into this heart i was like
don't worry you still have one more day in you one more day
so anyway my second monitor my to the left um it can't be
straight anymore oh my god congratulations your gain i mean
it's like it's just like what's the word it's just it just
can't stand up on its own anymore it it's like always
leaning down no matter how much i how much i've like pushed
it back up like and center it keeps leaning down every time
like there's no fixing it anymore i think the screws the
mount like i'm pretty sure you know like when the screws are
like worn down that it can't turn anymore because i've i've
screwed like i've used the screw to tighten it up so many
times That it just won't tighten up anymore You guys, it's
not, I can't salvage it It's literally on its defense Like,
like, he has his arm on his own plug And he's, he unplugged
himself He was like, I'll go out on my own terms And he
unplugged his, he unplugged the monitor By his, it's gone,
guys So I'm just trying to order a fucking new monitor arm
Yeah, yeah don't get no no it's over it's it's like you get
over it's like fully slanted down and i can't do anything
about it i have to be like like like this to see what the
second monitor says anyway give me a second also chat is not
up because i didn't change any settings i literally just got
home i was doing behind the scenes work which you'll find
out next week what it is uh it was supposed to be uh today
but now now it's it's tuesday which you're gonna find out on
tuesday i literally got home you're like why didn't you
order the monitor i'm earlier um well it died while i was
out so because it was it was fine this morning it was fine
this morning and then i came home and then i saw you know i
saw the crime scene where it was like fully bent down and
then it brought my main down with me but then like the right
arm it's it's like it's like a paris it's like a conjoined
twin you know uh one side is okay and the other is like
fucking dying the organ failure has yet to reach the other
twin so like that may the other twin is okay but then the
other the other one the twin next the other conjoined twin
that's actually dying is bringing the main twin down with it
push is pushing them down so uh so eventually the other twin
is also gonna die uh so i'm trying to order a new monitor
arm right now uh randy give it a super chat thank you thank
you i i ironically love this game it's ticketing as i've
never played it before uh i don't know if i'm a good typer
that's that's the thing i i don't know
So, we'll see.
I have played...
I actually did...
Okay, you might be thinking, Oh, that has to be me.
Okay, I forgot to be like, live now.
Be like, live now.
And you gotta do, like, those, like...
Remember the quarry?
Or is it quarry?
I don't remember.
Wait, make sure your hand is placed in the right area and
everything.
Also, I don't know it was a good idea to bring in the other
keyboard.
Bringing the wounding to keyboard because I'm not used to
it's very fast.
it is it types very very fast.
So I have my performance enhancer my performance enhancer
equipment here it is one of the best keyboards out there
because it's meant to what's the word it's meant to make it
so you can press buttons faster check her keyboard if she
doesn't win i even got my aim bot out i'm walling i'm gonna
start walling the other writers uh no it's actually crazy
how wounding is like it's insane how fast the wounding is
compared it's like one is currently the best keyboard out
there if you're like into like gaming competitive gaming and
stuff because it helps it it makes it so it's easier to uh
press the keys in a specific order for like movement and
shit like that um so fortunately it's not It is
scientifically proven and also is made by the Dutch so you
know they know their shit other than getting high
You know they know their shit.
It's it's very optimized It's a very optimized keyboard
agreed to cheat we all we all just if we all use it is it
technically is it cheating if also i'm so sad i wanted to
talk about the what was it that streamer cruise oh the
northern lion cruise and i was gonna like talk about it and
now it's canceled and i was like i couldn't make enough
content out of it before it got canceled i no the super
strike mouse is still outside the door i don't need So I was
just like, I'm just going to be typing.
So for those who don't know, Northern Lion, people thought
it was an AI website used to scam people, like scam the
Northern Lion fans.
But then Northern Lion made a stream, be like, yep, it's
real.
I'm going to be hosting a cruise themed around me and
streamers.
So it's just like getting a bunch of fans and gamers on a
cruise ship.
And then, I don't know, it just...
was on a ship I mean okay or Tanaka what if Tanaka was on a
ship and you're technically there's no laws when you're in
the sea so and I'm like thinking what Or Tanaka, what if
Tanaka was on a ship and you're stranded in the middle of
nowhere?
And then there's no laws on the ocean.
So, technically, there's no laws when you're in the sea.
So, and I'm like, think, what do you even do?
Like, what can you even, like, do on a streamer cruise?
as a streamer you know like yeah when you're on
international waters there's only some laws but that means
some other laws do not apply
so i was just like this could be a really really bad idea
depending on who is on this cruise uh and then it got
canceled it got canceled today so uh so like apparently all
refunds are process right i think i think he saw all the
very very bad ideas that people were coming up with on the
cruise and then he was like we gotta shut it down everyone
shut this shit down the fact that he used him as an example
for what the cruise would be like is still crazy to me
affiliate thank you with a super chat thank you thank you
i'm pretty sure he was like wait a minute
isn't as good of an idea as I thought it'd be.
And I'm like, I don't know.
There, the route for it was not ideal.
I was reading up a little bit about it
That's all I can say about the route.
I think, I'm pretty sure the cruise was planned before it
was closed.
Before, I'm pretty fucking sure.
And then they were like, maybe it'll be okay.
Oh, was that a meme?
Oh, thank God.
It's so hard to tell what's right.
Okay, thank God that was a meme because I couldn't tell what
was true and what wasn't only because the entire thing
didn't seem like it was true so i couldn't tell like what
was the truth or not anymore oh i couldn't tell the entire
concept didn't feel like it could be true uh god it was a
meme all right anyway i still need to order my monitor arm
all right i don't Okay, I'm not very good at monitor arms.
So I'm going to show you guys two pictures of a monitor arm.
And you guys tell me left or right.
Okay, three pictures.
I'll show you guys.
One, two, three.
Oh, no, the craziest part was it was $2,000 for ticket.
That was the craziest part.
It was $2,000.
Those PCs on that cruise better have some 50-90s if it's 2K
per ticket.
gaming room and everything i'm like how are you i guess it's
all going to be on land or some shit because i was going to
be like how are you going to game on in the middle of the
ocean uh uh ns thank you the super chat thank you thank you
i can just hold the monitor myself it'll be cheaper all
right guys one two or three they're all different monitors
and i don't know uh one is the msi monitor the other one is
a asus monitor uh they're both pretty big
there but one is i don't remember two for the rgb can't even
see it it's on the back two i guess okay wait two or three
apparently one is bad one not good enough all right okay two
holds 20 pounds per screen the other one holds also holds 20
pounds they both hold the the first one holds 22 pounds two
holds two and three holds 20 pounds
three because it looks like transformers
all right Three.
I see more threes.
Why not hold up?
This is my pull.
How do you translate three?
Three translates to three.
Like, I hate this function.
I fucking hate it so much.
I just see everyone be like horse.
And I know you guys are saying doki.
But I'm like, I have a name.
And everyone would be like, horse.dot, dot, dot.
Like, horse.dot, dot, dot.
all right three is better all right i'm ordering three nice
it has overnight shipping let's go no protection i believe
in my delivery man to not to not throw my package on the
floor i i believe so hard that it'll be okay Don't keep
please It's time For 50-50 Let's go
want my delivery guy to wake up earlier and to carry this
earlier.
Uh, rice, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Two or three look like gas spring arms, which are generally
easier to position.
One is only good for identical miners.
Okay.
All right.
Nice.
Thank you the super chat.
Rice.
Thank you.
All right.
Here we go.
You're so evil because I'm grouchy.
My, my other monitor arm died.
today and i couldn't save him i wasn't even there to watch
him die i couldn't even be there at his deathbed i came back
and it was too late he was already gone oh yeah okay let me
he's crunchy all right get me to see uh
uh okay let me answer this Work message real quick.
all right here we go all right anyway today wait oh you guys
like my sorry do you like as like my keyboard ASMR with my
wounding two I had the wounding one but now I have the
wounding two whoa yes I have to update my keyboard to make
it even faster guys it's a competition I would be top 500 in
final sentence I actually don't know how fast I actually
type though.
I've been, I used to type like, um, for the longest time.
Also, why am I froze?
Like, for the longest, I don't know.
I think it was like, okay, even though I had like computer
lab growing up, um, I, and I did like the keyboard exercises
where like, you know, uh, like those like typing games or
typing, educational typing programs for kids, uh, for
students.
And then you're like, well, make sure your left hand and
your right hand are positioned in and on work.
I don't even know on A, S, D, F, G, F, J, K, L, and then I
would like not learn.
I would not take in instructions properly.
so I would type with my fingers like just be like with the
two like the two fingers and stuff because like I didn't
care and I always have to look at my hands when I'm typing
too when I try to do the position like the the actual typing
position I would have to look at my hand to know where I'm
typing and it was only when I started role-playing in Neal
Pets where when I finally learned how to type properly
because I had to type fast because like there's a lot you
know whoever whoever I've done Neil Pitts roleplay where
everybody's on the boards and then you have to like make a
response quick or the board will die or the other role
player will leave so I had to learn how to type fast so I
can continue the roleplay my high school AU roleplay my war
I had to learn how to type fast for my warrior cat's role
play on my neopets board you don't understand wild pelt had
to answer had to go on a hunt to earn to go on patrol for
thunder clan it was important we gotta do it for the role
play i need to know what happens to wild pelt
so that was the only one that was the that was the how i
learned how to type really really fast shout out to my
neopets roleplay board uh anyway that's how i actually
became more literate too i was very i did not care much
about reading or writing until i got into neopets
roleplaying
We were all cringe when we were kids.
Oh, I'm sorry for having a childhood.
Like, I refused to read, like, chapter books or, like, any
type of books growing up, because I thought books were
boring.
And also, like, I, and also chapter books.
I was like, I liked, I think, like, the only books I read
were picture books for the longest time until I started
role-playing on Neopets because I had to learn more words to
be more literate, to be like more cultured because I wanted
to look cool in front of all the college kids on Neopets.
Okay, for those who don't know, Neopets was originally a
website made for college students, made for college
students, and it was just mostly college.
you need the parents permission to be on it because uh and
my parents actually faxed my permission slip just so i can
hang out on the boards and talk to other fellow neopet users
neopians as they are called and so i wanted to look cool in
front of my new friends in front of my new older friends And
I was like, I was like, oh my God, I gotta, I gotta learn
more words.
I gotta, I gotta learn more words.
I can role play better and be more cultured and literate.
And, um, and what's the, oh my God, I'm losing my words
because I stopped reading.
I, what's that other word for knowing lots of words?
Word for knowing a lot of words.
I stopped role-playing.
I got them.
No, I started reading fan fiction.
That's what I started reading fan fiction and then they went
downhill from there.
It was consequences of my actions.
Because I would end up like, you know, when I actually got
into like reading, I actually read like books, hardcover
books and everything.
And I had like, like, I had three shelves just filled.
with my entire my like book collection and i discovered
fanfiction.net i was like wow i can read on my phone i and
then i learned the words i learned was not very helpful in
expanding my vocabulary through fanfiction that's a03 before
a03 yeah fanfiction.net then a03 recovering by the way no
it's okay it's okay i'm i'm better now i'm better i'm that
that life is behind me all right thank welcome to tomato
farm welcome welcome it's okay ex ex fujo by the i'm ex fujo
i've reformed now guys that life is behind me now uh
Final sentence It is a typing battle royale the only issue
is that I heard I said this before but I heard cheating is
like hackers are Yes, and I'll be on it when it does come
up, but
for now there's no leaderboard or anything um so there's
like there's actual like hackers in the game trying to be i
don't even know how i guess like i guess it's just like the
ai fucking doing the type things like for like in 0.1 second
and they finish typing yeah it's just it's just it's just
the love of the game they can't win on anything else so they
have to win on final sentence I hope, I don't know if Sound
Guy is here, but it's time to play your favorite game, Sound
Guy.
Papa, thank you for Magenta Soup, but thank you, thank you.
Thanks for another year around.
The sun has a dragon.
Thanks for working so hard on this project.
Just for my birthday, not the Lulu.
Can this old mad dragon get an early song since you'll be
traveling?
Of course!
Yes, I will not be here on Friday and Saturday, guys.
But I'll be back on Sunday or Monday.
I don't, actually, I don't even remember.
But, oh my God, is it called the end?
Is that what the game is called?
Is that actually...
Why am I lagging?
I'm just typing.
Thank you again for the magenta soupa.
Thank you.
All right, let me get in a typing position real quick.
Oh, all right, I got Extendo my cable so that it is in front
of me.
And I got put, I'm actually going to lock in here.
All right.
All right, I'm ready.
Battle Royale time.
We actually, let's double check every Show our FPS, show our
ping, so I can blame ping if we lose, as always, as a real
gamer, it should.
wait there's no push to talk wait so they'll just hear my
stream of consciousness if i yeah no that's not good you'll
be like there's a i will let them know that there is a
streamer in the lobby uh
oh dear don't worry i lowered my microphone because then so
then they won't know that there's a They'll incentivize them
to say some words.
All right, I'm ready.
of us in the lobby now there's four of us in here all right
all right i'm ready i'm locking in my aim i'm gonna start
embodying the words i'm even bought the letters on my
keyboard i'm looking at my keyboards while i'm typing to
make sure i type the right things how many people are in a
lobby oh six slots oh oh control is voice chat The game
begins now.
Ah!
No!
Okay, it's okay.
I'm not the first one to die.
I'm not it's all right
Tokyo's a fucking drill Where is the quick brown fox jumps
over the
It's not next to each other.
The R.
It's skipped E.
They think Q-W-R is skipped E.
Just the read it type.
I use W-A-S-D, not Q-W-E.
Oh my god.
No,
no, I typed it!
Ah!
Oh my god, I'm typing too fast.
I'm typing too fast!
It's too good!
This keyboard is too good!
Oh no!
Oh.
Oh, no!
No!
I'm still alive.
Okay.
We're still in it.
Where is I still in it?
oh my god oh my god I'm bad figuring my words
I'm, my fingers are shaking.
I'm shaking right now.
A new profile.
Okay, when is it higher?
Makes it...
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, there you go.
Save this.
All right.
Save the new my new profile.
Okay
It's a real...
We're actually there.
I'm actually trapped in there typing for my life.
I'm so immersed.
Okay.
The game begins now.
I'll go slower.
54 France.
Okay.
Paris Hall of the
Oh, it's so numbers.
Numbers.
Oh, not the numbers.
Okay.
Italy, Florence, Garden of the Veil!
Oh, goodbye!
Goodbye, everyone!
That's right!
I'm a survivor!
I did it!
Oh my god!
I told you guys, I told you guys, once it started being real
words, when it's a real word, I understand.
I forgot to, I forgot to change my bit rate, guys.
Is the, is the, is the, is it, is it a little blurry?
Is the stream a little choppy?
Because I can't make it back to the original bitrate.
All right.
Lock in, bro.
We live another day.
Just remember to redeem our Amazon gift cards.
All right.
Okay.
Just remember to redeem our Amazon gift cards.
All right.
Okay.
Oh Oh Oh Alright, oh no, no, no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no
We're okay.
What's knockdown?
There's six players.
There's no limit to the number of mistakes you can make.
Your input is blocked for the text is divided.
All players start.
The last player in the round is eliminated.
Oh, wait, this is fun.
Let's try knockdown.
Let's see what this gives us.
All right, I'm ready
No, but my PC has auto correct all I have to do is just My
PC has auto correct
moment, so at least I'm not eliminated first.
I gotta
Oh, there he is.
Goodbye.
How am I lagging?
All I do is type.
Oh, no.
Oh, it's getting closer.
I don't use punctuation.
I just type.
I have to do periods!
Ah!
Goodbye, document.
but balance what balance
okay i guess we
quality i guess we don't have that option patch your ass and
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you goodbye
donkey bird all right do we have this space disable any of
these or if it is good i guess we only have two choice wait
maybe if i do medium can i do balance nope it's just you
know i don't need better graphics for typing right it's just
i'm just typing okay what's this oh i get a little little
crane resolution scale i couldn't guys if i guys i'm
pressing it it's You don't own, there's no choice.
All I have, I just have, it's just, it's like, you want
performance, performance, or performance?
It's just, all I have, it's just performance.
No, it won't let me.
I use my keyboard.
I don't, I, I am, I am.
press enter all right okay maybe I'm still lagging a little
before it's like you are you sure oh you wanted performance
right all right let me close some tabs maybe that I should
have done that first actually I should I should have done
that should have been the first thing I did today all right
Let me close my tabs real quick.
I have a lot of tabs.
They were work-related, though.
They are work-related tabs.
All right, let's see.
Oh, my God.
I'm still closing tabs, guys.
Oh, I forgot to mention, girlfriend is now on Spotify, guys.
I had people that were like, why did you remove your other
upload?
Because it wasn't even me.
Like, that was me.
even my my upload I had to remove it so I could fucking so I
could upload my actual song but it's now officially it's now
officially uh on streaming platforms so it's on Spotify
Apple Amazon YouTube and the rest are that's the ones I know
oh it's a lot better now oh my crazy maybe i shouldn't have
like 80 tabs open the tabs could have been the issue all
right battle royale
it was the tabs it was the tabs all along who would have
thought i did have a lot of tabs on i will admit there were
there were quite a few tabs up all right who would have
thought Alright, I think Battle Royale is easier.
contestants the game begins now
okay i had to go slower because i did not have a lot wow it
was a tab so oh my god it's better now it was the tabs all
along wait for the light no no no no no no i'm waiting i can
do better i promise no i don't know ah
I'll go slower.
Oh my god.
Everyone's dying with the first shot.
No!
Please, please, please.
I'm number one.
You need me.
I typed so fast.
I
think also like it punishes fast type
Pull it past it Slower, not slow, but not too slow
okay wait capitalization doesn't count oh but fucking
periods does okay that's
I don't have to capitalize That's good
Oh my god are you fucking kidding me
Shoot!
Patience!
There are so many punctuations, sir!
Sir!
I'm dead anyway.
That guy is so ahead of me.
That guy is so ahead.
I'll go on my own test.
You go get me right now.
I'm not going to get me.
I won't let him have the satisfaction
No!
These aren't words!
Oh no.
Yeah, I did one game of knockout and I was just like, nah.
Okay.
Oh!
No,
no, no, no, no.
He's fucking crying!
God damn, don't raid me!
Oh my god!
Because it didn't There you go.
Oh me?
Oh my god.
We I thought I thought we no
Alex!
I wish this was like Street Fighter where I could block a
player and they'll never be matched against them again.
I'll...
E-O-M-M finally clicked.
I swear to God if it's you again, Alex.
Oh my God, I swear to God.
I can't see your name, but I swear, thank God.
Get me out of here!
It's the competitive type.
it as far as I did.
And it's always the punctuation.
It's always the fucking punch.
Alright.
Dole is definitely hard.
I don't use variants.
I don't I always have to second guess where it's located.
I don't know where it is.
I have to look down.
Okay.
No, get out of here!
Nobody likes you!
Oh my god, and then they gave me numbers!
And then they gave me numbers!
oh my god oh my god just shoot me just put five bullets in
there thank you thank you thank you
it's just put five more bullets in the chamber
i have to type taxless and numbers like what was i supposed
to do we wait a little bit maybe a baby well i swear to god
if i get this guy a third fucking time in a row i i swear to
god if i see him again
dodging.
I'm queuing dodging this.
I swear to God, if I... Okay, Ronald.
Ronald.
Oh my god!
Oh, I have kept...
What?
Okay, I was like, H2-0, H2-0, H2-0, oh, oh my god, it's O
again, it's, can you tell that chemistry was not my best
subject?
Oh my god
Thank you.
I just don't want to type this anymore.
I don't want to type fucking chemistry notes anymore.
I don't want to type chemistry notes.
Holy shit.
Government mandated wood.
to god if i i swear to god what's your name okay digital
stop okay it's not chemistry
oh my god i i can't i cannot deal periods i cannot i give me
a sentence with give me an 80 word run-on sentence please
please i just need an eight
It doesn't matter It doesn't matter anymore Just get leave
me out of here Just just get me out of here It's always the
periods after the periods I can't lock
back in.
It just infuriates me.
It fucking makes me so angry.
It totally itchy.
It makes me so angry.
I just start tripping.
Okay.
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm fucking ready.
Battle Royale.
At least in Battle Royale.
Oh yeah, that's where all the children hang out.
I don't understand why can they not give me an 80-80 word
run-on census with no punctuation whatsoever.
Oh.
The game begins now.
Oh my god.
I don't even know.
want to win.
Just shoot me.
I don't even...
I don't even want to be here anymore.
our own lobby, guys.
A broken text?
A post, man.
Game cheats?
Oh.
Okay.
This is all of it.
No bots.
Zero bots.
Capitals matter.
Okay.
One mistake.
Let's go.
Wait.
Alright.
Here's my lobby.
Here it is.
Capitals matter and there's only one mistake.
mistake all of those speed typers it's gonna get one of them
it's gonna get one of the speed typers guys all right i'll
do five more seconds five four is three two one all right it
won't get me I'd win by the fact that I'd be the last one
standing.
If I'm the last one standing, I'd win.
much energy.
I'm ready.
Why is no one making mistakes?
No!
Let's go!
Oh no!
Oh!
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, please, please, please, please,
please, please, please not last.
I can't even see guys Not last
wins it's a tie everyone tied guys everyone tied nobody
loses when nobody wins exactly no all right all right guys
here's everyone it's a tie nobody won and
nobody lost.
I fucking knew it.
Good luck Alex.
Good luck, Alex.
If you can, if you think you can
one mistake.
Alright.
It's alright.
I believe in us.
I believe in no one winning.
Like if I believe in in the fact that no one can win if no
one wins I win okay I'm so fucking locked in
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I pressed another T.
I double tapped.
It was a simple but still.
Okay, that one, that one doesn't count.
towards famous leader review oh lorem those are fun to wait
lorem there we now now this is a battle
But now it's a real battle royale.
Welcome, contestants.
The game begins now.
It's laden time.
Oh my god.
race okay all right okay not last in fact halfway there yeah
oh oh another shot
That was in first place
I'm second place now, baby
Wait, the guy behind me!
You know what?
He's going so slow now.
There's some real horseshits.
Not gonna lie.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I got second, though.
I got second.
Um.
Don't talk to me when you get first.
He's actually typing one by one.
He was actually on the last mistake.
He's going so slow.
Just one mistake.
He's on the final stretch.
He's painted to win.
You're your tippy-taps.
Just one more word.
One more word.
Oh my god.
Flying Panda, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Broken backwards.
Broken text.
Anime top 10.
Wait, actually?
That guy was the main character.
journeys and oh my god there's so many numbers someone
already made a mistake i hurt the gun clock oh mistake
number two all right one episode out already number one no
buddy I've seen this before.
Is this all fairing?
Okay.
Pull down.
Beyond.
Journey.
In season 1.
9.
Point 2.
8.
Slash.
10.
20, 20, 20.
No, no, I typed, oh my god, the capital letters, oh, it's
the capital letters, please, oh,
Oh, all right.
Number three.
now i'm number two now
oh seven out of ten okay a microwave
okay oh i do a lot it's you and me well there is one guy at
the very back.
I don't know if you guys see him.
He's still alive.
Right at the very back.
That was six.
No!
Oh my god, I typed the C before I typed the O!
Please, anyone, no, why are these others?
I want to know.
Oh my god, I typed the C.
I typed the C.
It's only one guy left
Oh, we're all... Wait, who's the guy up over there?
Yay, no one won!
This game is what goes after Chitama will never know This
game is actually so intense.
I'm already so fucking tired Oh my god, it's so stressful it
really is
I always get the ones that had the most fucking punctuations
or just oops all numbers I swear to get I swear to get I
swear to get what if what are my prompts Okay, it's cooking.
Oh my god.
It's all numbers.
It's
Oh, I spelled ingredients with an a
Oh, okay.
Maybe it'll be a baby.
Maybe I'll fight a baby.
Maybe.
Maybe it won't be an actual gamer.
all right all right here we go i'm ready i'm locked in all
right i'm locked in i'm not epi i am a little epi but like
i'm so locked in guys i'm ready i'm ready to type i'm ready
to make it worth your wild it'll be like
I'm so locked in.
I'm so locked in
There we go.
Oh shit.
to that one.
There we go.
Oh my god, it's like he knew how I felt.
I'm just writing reviews.
I really am.
No!
Okay.
It was me all along.
Oh my god, this guy doesn't have punctuations.
But the game has taught me to use punctuation.
And now I have to unlearn punctuation.
No!
And mine is 10 out of 10.
No on, on, no, no, no, no, on, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no,
none.
Okay, okay.
One finger, baby.
That was actually two fingers.
There's the one on the end, the other on the oh, I, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I think that was
a good sentence to end on.
chat because I imagine asking you for more of your rare
parent from fantastic artists mr.
broken bond thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
that was fun I don't even I don't even know what this game
this was it was truly an experience anyway guys I'll see you
guys next week when I'm Well, one three days.
I'll see you guys in three days.
I won't be streaming on Friday or Saturday, but I'll be back
on my regular schedule on Sunday.
Most likely I won't be streaming on Sunday.
But maybe on Monday.
Maybe.
Anyway, guys.
I'm gonna call it here, everyone.
As always, everybody.
Say hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around and get that blood flowing.
You stay up for me.
Head to bed because you deserve it.
Tuesday is the big announcement.
announcement guys big announcement most likely it might be
at i might do a stream around 3 p.m i think that might be
the time i'm not sure yet it's not fully confirmed but i'm
just putting it out there for now just feeling it anyways
i'll see you guys next time everybody bye bye i'm so tired
i'm gonna fucking take a nap i'm actually gonna go straight
to taking a nap i'm so exhausted from that that was so
mentally and physically exhausting anyway bye everyone Bye!